that's like me meeting an American and
going oh when I was little I wanted to
have type 2 diabetes you can
probably what do you what do you do with
your days uh well I work for as an event
producer as an event producer you have
any tips for us
here book fewer British people [__] off
who heck called that I'm out of drinks
that's you're you're you're out of
drinks well that's because it's the end
of the show so that's you didn't time
your drinking correctly what type of
events do you produce running events
running events holy [__] that's CU
you're wearing an on-running shorts and
sneakers look that's how impressed
Runners are when they talk about the
runners High I'm like these are just
easily satisfied people surely you are
you a runner yourself signed up for the
New York Marathon sign up for the New
York Marathon that doesn't mean you're a
runner means he's attempting to me the
fun thing about marathons is it's one of
the only times you're legally allowed to
[__] and piss in public isn't
it cuz yeah cuz you're running and you
can just be like ha that's
why I did that when I run the marathon
but um unfortunately I was wearing a
novelty bear costume at the time so
that's a silly joke in it when you were
when you were a little kid then did you
want to be an event planner for running
things surely
not what was part of your plan when you
were a little one professional soccer
player professional soccer player Al so
you know I can relate have you seen me
do
any what a horrendous racist
stereotype that's like me meeting an
American and going oh when I was little
I wanted to have type 2 diabetes you can
probably probably relate to
that who was your who was your team that
you wanted to play
forit Arenal Arsenal okay so someone
over here who say who's at mancher
United you you did you want to be a
soccer player no not at all no Chris
that [__] gay
sport do you mind if I ask what you do
to earn your goni
T-shirt you oh a small business but one
day it's going to be a medium
business what what is your small
business a sneaker laundry service
Marketplace I feel really self-conscious
these are not Sparkling White right now
but um yeah 100 bucks aren't they you
just buy a new pair and when you were a
little one what did you want to do Air
Force Air Force oh so Air Force now you
work with Air Force Ones hey hey
hey is it a joke I don't know Air Force
did you did you were you in the Air
Force no my dad's coard my brother's
Army your dad's Coast Guard your
brother's Army you were like we could
complete the set but
I feel like dad's Coast Guard is Coast
Guard is less killing people isn't it
your brother was like [__] that [__] um
you pull them out the water I'll gun him
down wow okay cool that's pretty cool
and then do you mind if I ask how you
make a living in the
city you said that so quietly which
makes me think that everyone would hate
you if you said it what what what is
it's for de I couldn't even hear it it
was like it's like if someone asks you
what do you do and you're like oh I have
an arms dealer you're going to
reply what is it that you do financial
adviser okay that's not that bad yeah
you you take 1% of all the rich people's
money right or more than that do you
charge
more you won't say she charges more what
how how how good are you at advising
that you're taking more than 1% dep it
depends how much money you have she
she's the best of all of you three
[__] missing
things okay as a as a little one what
did you want to
do doctor doctor so the world's loss is
your own personal
game that's good what's your favorite
body
part you didn't see her face then all
the direction she
looked none that's why you're not a
doctor so you aspired to be it and then
someone was like look at this gaping
wound you're like [__]
that literally what happened that's
literally what happened really oh my
gosh okay you were in medical school and
then left okay no this is an amazing
story you the first time they were like
okay so this is a person you were like I
beg your
pardon wow okay I love it so we've got a
person who wanted to be in the Air Force
and instead uh cleans runs a sneaker
cleaning business you run running events
and that fun that's nice uh and
financial advisor and you want to be a
soccer player and you want to be well
you were medal school okay um Alicia my
lovely DJ would you do me a favor would
you drop that beat uh yeah that's what
I'm talking about this is cuz I you
don't know this cuz I'm in the UK in the
UK I'm A A hip-hop Legend over here a
fewer people know but I like to
freestyle rap that's making up raps
about whatever's happen what's my name
well I mean let's see if I'm any good
first so they like what's your hip-hop
name I'm actually Eminem oh look at that
um so we're going to make a wrap out
what's just happened uh here maybe we
can turn the volume down a little bit
it's slightly loud debels in the
speakers I'm walking outside got the
street upon my sneak cu the dirt's
flirting with the out soole and the
upper it's difficult to get the leather
better with the rubber more synthetic
only guy that knows he's like this is
really true I would clean the clothes
but no need for chemicals I just start
to scrub a small business but we're
expanding bro if you're on the court and
get the scuffs on your feet don't worry
got the little chemicals that I can
treat 30 to 60 more if they're Nifty you
see a nice pair like maybe I should Nick
these Air Force Ones to Air Force you
were there saying Dad yes I adore in the
Coast Guard people swim and then they
drown your brother's like nah I send
them back down to a watery grave one
between the eyes you were like me or my
I would not advise aiming for the skies
in the Air Force coming down now the guy
yeah what does he care for all of the
runners they run fast thin and they
think it's so fun until they get the
shin splints that's the difficulty
you're tearing your ACL or your Cal
muscle happens in the soccer game as
well it often puts people on the bench
injuries took your shirt off like I
should mention you want to wear it
sharing the clothes it's probably sweaty
bro cuz I know you're signing up for the
marathon you won't have a smile once
you've styled through their 26 miles 2.4
It's All Greek to me cuz it's invented
by the Greeks literally but you were sat
there looking COI looking Prim I asked
what you do the guy with no chin and you
whispered yes right inside there you're
like I'm a financial advisor a heaven
sent more than 1% if you got a lot of
money don't know what to do with it you
can tell them it's pretty easy no just
put it in stocks and watch it grow or a
Tracker fund I'm not trying to lose you
work I'm just saying in the past yeah
you chose to sh responsibilities you're
like look what's on offer I'll help you
I'll become a doctor someone walks up to
you really sick they're like please
diagnose me really quick you're like
wait what I have to deal with people and
flesh and blood and just feel and
palpate and if the Runner comes in
example if this guy walks in with his
shins all bleeding he's like I tripped
on the road what am I going to do you
well you'd know probably you'd bandage
it you'd do a sprain fixing that oh and
it's such a bloody shame but don't worry
you're stacking cash having such fun and
if you go for a run and The Rumble in
your tum you get the runs in the
marathon let it run free that's a
diarrhea pun that you get from me and if
you're doing this if you produce the poo
and it dribbles down your thigh and goes
to your shoes what you going to do
you're feeling so Keen you're like I
need to get my running sneakers clean
and so my guy when you've done your
dirty business get his work and increase
his business
you guys are delightful my name is